Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1925,
Frida Kahlo andaba de regreso de
la escuela en la ciudad de México
cuando el autobús en el que iba
chocó contra un tranvía.
Sufrió heridas casi fatales
en columna, pelvis y cadera
que la mantuvo en cama varios meses.
Mientras se recuperaba
tenía un caballete especial
ajustado a su cama
donde practicaba técnicas de pintura.
Cuando comenzó a trabajar
pintaba el mundo según
su propia visión singular.
Durante toda su vida
se establecería como la creadora y
la musa detrás de su arte extraordinario.
Si bien seguro conoces la mirada de Kahlo,
su trabajo nos brinda la oportunidad
de ver el mundo a través de sus ojos.
Pintó a amigos y familiares,
naturaleza muerta y escenas espirituales;
pero son sus fascinantes autorretratos
los que capturaron la atención
del mundo por primera vez.
En una de sus primeras obras,
"Autorretrato con vestido de terciopelo",
el enfoque es en sus cejas gruesas, vello
facial, cuello largo y mirada fuerte.
Estas características se mantienen
aunque Kahlo pronto comenzaría
a presentarse de forma inusual.
Por ejemplo,
en "La columna rota" usa simbolismo,
imágenes religiosas y un paisaje destruido
para revelar su estado físico y mental.
En 1928, Kahlo comenzó a salir
con el pintor Diego Rivera.
Fueron pareja durante toda la vida
y cultivaron una fama excéntrica.
Viajaron juntos por el mundo
y se dedicaron al arte,
a la política comunista
y el nacionalismo mexicano.
Kahlo y Rivera compartían una profunda
afinidad con la mexicanidad,
un movimiento que celebraba la cultura
indígena después de la revolución.
En su vida cotidiana, Kahlo
vestía el traje típico de tehuana
y estaba inmersa en
la espiritualidad indígena.
Y en su trabajo
hacía referencia constante
a la pintura folclórica mexicana
al incorporar sus vivos colores
y sus referencias a la muerte,
la religión y la naturaleza.
Con sus imágenes de
flores gigantes flotantes,
paisajes ondulantes, trasplantes
de partes humanas y nubes de demonios,
a Kahlo se le asocia con frecuencia
con el surrealismo.
Pero mientras que los surrealistas
usan imágenes de ensueño
para explorar la mente inconsciente,
Kahlo las usaba para representar su cuerpo
físico y las experiencias de su vida.
Dos de sus experiencias más exploradas
fueron su discapacidad física
y su matrimonio.
Debido al accidente del autobús
Kahlo tuvo problemas de salud
durante toda su vida
y fue hospitalizada muchas veces.
Con frecuencia contemplaba
los efectos físicos y psicológicos
de la discapacidad en su trabajo;
al pintarse agonizando,
recuperándose de operaciones,
o incluyendo objetos como la abrazadera
para su espalda y la silla de rueda.
Mientras tanto, su relación
con Rivera era tempestuosa
marcada por la infidelidad de ambos.
Hasta llegaron a divorciarse
y a casarse nuevamente el año siguiente.
Durante ese período
pintó el doble autorretrato
"Las dos Fridas",
donde muestra el dolor de la pérdida
y un sentido de sí mismo astillado.
La Frida de la izquierda
tiene el corazón roto
y gotea sangre sobre
su vestido victoriano antiguo.
Simboliza la versión de la artista
que fue herida en el pasado...
pero también está conectada por medio
de una arteria a una segunda imagen.
Esta Frida viste un traje de tehuana...
y aunque recuerda a Diego con
una imagen en miniatura en la mano,
su corazón permanece intacto.
Las dos imágenes juntas sugieren
un sentimiento de estar atrapada
entre el pasado y el presente,
entre el individualismo y la dependencia.
Kahlo falleció en 1954
a los 47 años de edad.
En años posteriores,
su popularidad aumentó y
la misma continúa hasta el presente.
Y aunque su imagen ha proliferado,
la obra de Kahlo
nos recuerda que la realidad
sobre la vida, el trabajo y el legado
de la mujer detrás del ícono
no es tan sencilla.
Kahlo nos mostró múltiples
versiones de su realidad...
y con eso nos abrió varias ventanas
hacia el interior de su alma.